let's bring in Ashish now as well and uh
we were waiting to see if this
ultimately came through and as as feared
it has uh talk us through uh the key
takeaways
what we'll see over the the coming weeks
is first of all the RCN will announce
its strike dates they they will be
before the end of the year we understand
they could extend into next year as well
they have a mandate with their ballots
of extending strike action up until May
next year I think so they've got six
months but we're likely to see the first
strike dates being announced uh over the
coming days possibly uh into next week
but certainly we will see strike action
at hospitals and trusts before the end
of the year now this has been it it's
not a national strike because not every
hospital trust has voted to go on strike
so what we'll see we'll see hospitals
where they have voted for industrial
action taking industrial action whereas
you might have a trust further down uh
you know in that region which has voted
not to take strike action but certainly
you will see industrial action in all
four countries in England Wales Northern
Ireland and in Scotland too emergency
and Urgent services will not be affected
that's according to the RCN the nurses
unit and according to the government it
says it has contingency plans in place
in fact next week the NHS starts its
winter preparedness exercises arctic
willow which will test its winter
preparedness and also tests or stress
tests how well trusts are equipped to
cope when industrial action does happen
I understand from speaking to Union
activists what has happened in the past
in Northern Ireland when there has been
industrial action they have strike
committees in hospitals which monitor
the level of starving on a particular
Ward if Staffing Falls below that at any
given time then nurses who are on a
picket line might be brought in to join
other staff or colleagues on that Ward
or they might have to shut that Ward so
even though urgent and Emergency Care
will continue and Cancer Care will
continue There Will Be disruption to
elective care routine appointments and
other forms of treatments I asked Pat
Cullen whether she felt conflicted by
this and whether she had anything to say
to a patient who might have been waiting
for months to finally getting their
appointment to getting their routine
procedure what would she say to those
patients who might be affected by those
strikes and she said it's not in our
hands it's in the hands of the
government we are striking to make sure
that patients who are waiting on that
elective backlog can be seen quickly and
effectively and that's only if the
government employs and recruits and
trains and retains the nurses to make
our hospitals work better so she says
it's in the hospital she says it's in
the government's hands also
the RCN is asking for five percent over
inflation inflation currently running at
around 12 so they're asking for between
16 to 17 way above what the government
has already offered I said is that
negotiable and she says we want to
negotiate with the government my door is
always open we want the government to
come to the table and see what the
government offers so clearly there is
some maneuverability there there is a
little room for negotiation but the two
the two sides the government and the
nurses Union so far apart at the moment
it looks like some strike dates will be
announced and Industrial action will be
inevitable